heim zu sammeln und willkommen zu einer
neuen folge keymet heute mit einem ganz
besonderen gast das wird ziemlich schwer
zu erreichen vor allem muss ich dann das
management anschreiben und es war mega
mega schwer überhaupt an ihn ranzukommen
aber wir haben heute hier in meiner
küche
mein heutiger gast ist bis 18 uhr sind
das vielleicht 40 eigene gruppe irgendwo
keine normale ehe oder nervt dich dass
man frei haben sie zuweilen ende
öffentlich weil haben sitzt er auf der
kanzel nervig da will ich einfach nur
hammer sein also und dann komme ich dann
sehe ich die mal doch wieder auch kiki
gibt auch leute die in deinem umfeld die
das nicht hast sind lächerliche ziehen
oder anstandsgefühl das muss sagen kann
schon sagen dass recht viele berichtet
auch freunde dann sehen aber immer so
ein bisschen erfolg kommen auf einmal
dann die zugestellt
das ist warum das ist meine stadt
ich sag mal so ein pedro normal kriegt
ja auch mal kennen einfach was hat hat
auch marktes getragen ich hätte ihn
gerne gerne gerne mitgenommen weil er
war noch nie in palästina seit dem 4
wir sind hier doch nicht heute haben uns
das ganz besonderes überlegt warum
gedacht haben sagte gaßmann
und gleichzeitig müssen uns auch für das
gesamte da ich weiß es rauschen wird
wenn ich jetzt einen job
wir haben überlegt wir wollten uns
eigentlich auch für das ganze jahr
bedanken wollen dass jahre wie passiert
säuren rückblick ein rückblick mit dir
zusammen und ich bin echt froh dass
sollte man das zimmer verfügt uns jetzt
die kamera kann man allein an der macht
ist einfach eine kamera dabei sein
fahrzeug aber heute ist meiner kamera
damit es einfacher zu steuern
hahaha die arbeit ruft
handy und auch lautlos computer was
jemand geschrieben
wir kochen auch wasser wir haben ja
hungern
wir machen heute preis mit einem
hähnchen gericht und ein bisschen spinat
lausanne plätze tauschen dann kannst du
die zwiebeln schneiden und ich wollte
schreiben
nein ich muss aber hinterher
ach so ja wieso kannst du gibst also die
globen und körper habe ich schon
geschnitten kannst du die zwiebel
schneiden und ich mache jetzt den reis
oder und dann eigentlich geht es ja auch
ein bisschen und mein gast
deswegen geht es gut und ich bin sehr
schlechter gar nicht reden aber mir geht
es gut wie geht es ihnen
hier kommen können so fragen die leute
wissen schon wie ich
aber es gibt noch nicht einmal die sich
wissen also haben wir ihn nicht auch mit
ihrem fall gesagt also also einfach zu
formulieren
ich glaube dass wir ungefähr zwei aber
und ob sie tun ja jetzt doppelt so
schwer dass zeitgleich sind sie sehr
viel weniger also davon ausgehen dass
vielleicht helfer mit besserung
vielleicht ausgeht dass wir vielleicht
sogar letzten monaten auch mal dieses
dichters aber zu bekommen haben wissen
vielleicht einige nicht wie ich bin ja
weil er muss mich darauf ins dorf zu
wissen wie ich bestimmt also man hansa
auf instagram verfolgt dann erkennt man
ganze persönlichkeit hinter haben
zumindest steckt ja schon meine mutter
durch ja jetzt ist es einfach ganze
sache stellen und dann fängst du an so
geschäft müssen wir sind ja wir würden
einfach mal anderen das jahr revue
passieren zu lassen oder auch für alle
die wirklich jetzt so nur straight
unsere rezepte gucken und auf youtube
scheint auch nicht viel durch von uns
habe ich das gefühl er wirklich auf
installationen will ich einfach mal sein
einfach erstmal so grundlegend
was ist eigentlich so haben das aufgabe
da was ist deine aufgabe bei kirche
sketchen was machst du eigentlich in
europa es stimmt ich bin so 12 box und
tatsächlich alles so ich mache also
gesagt dass filme ich ja das für mit der
2k also ist im raum gehe ich nur haben
sie und ich wenn wir rezepte für euch
haben und kann durch unsere genau machst
du die fotos auf den fotos für unseren
online shop machte haben
hast du das gelernt dass dein beruf nein
das habe ich nicht getan ich habe das
alles mir selbst bei war ja ihr habt hat
sich auch viel über ihn ist es natürlich
so eine lernplattform ob es nun rezepte
sind oder sich das filmen oder oder
schöner stellt man auch von anderen wenn
man andere trifft dann so ich glaube ich
auch jetzt vor kurzem haben wir uns ja
mit bizkit schon wieder im schnee hoch
ist tristan gerät da kann man von ihm
und er hätten auch gut zu tun
genau um sitze genauso das mache ich das
kann wie das macht ja auch jetzt also er
schneidet und bearbeitet die kompletten
wie das auf den loks wenn sie mal kommen
die mache ich dann unterschied merkt
dann auch die qualitätsunterschiede
nicht ertrag bringe und den duellen tag
bringt schon mal kurz erwähnt haben kurz
daran ja gratis besuchen
merk ich bin gelenkig auch ich bin auch
eigentlich jura experte ich glaube du
bist ein bisschen bescheiden ein
bisschen sehr bescheiden sogar denn das
was haben sie auch noch macht ist
shopmanagement haben sie ist
gleichzeitig irgendwie informatik
programmiert haben ein starkes
programmierer team mittlerweile aber das
hat mir die ganze zeit ja ich hatte zwar
ein bisschen hilfe gehabt aber das war
jetzt nicht in diesem umfang hat auch
später auch woher die nachfrage schon
viel viel größer sagt auch gar nicht
mehr hinterherkommen dass wir unbedingt
ein team hinter uns haben also ein
externes programm auf jeden fall aber
gott sagen und dann sagen wir es auch
haben sie als immer ansprechpartner also
kriegt am tag wirklich ohne zu
übertreiben bis zum bis 18 uhr sind das
vielleicht 40 eingehende anrufe alles
mit fragen die nicht nur im speziellen
sondern einmal hamza
lassen was ist kaputt was mache ich
jetzt oder dass man das funktioniert
nicht dass du kriegst schon also dass
schon eine heftige verantwortung 5
es gibt ja mittlerweile auch schon über
24 allerdings ohne job so ausgabe haben
wir nochmal andere mitarbeiter die uns
behilflich sind dafür zu kommen durch
später ist so ja also ich kriege echt
sehr viele anrufe was auch viele der
schutz tun hat das heißt haben es ein
richtiger allrounder oder wenn es zum
beispiel darum geht wir haben ja unser
es kann ich sagen lieblingsprodukten
viele lieblingsprodukte aber dass
strauss gewesen es war die öl ist ja
wirklich auch gesundheit nicht so das
non-plus-ultra und da zum beispiel jetzt
haben sie auch hinterher das heißt sie
brauchen jetzt aber gute verband kartons
und so das sind kleinigkeiten wie sehr
hier nicht aber als dieser noch
mitmachen das ist mir echt heftig glaube
ich auch im einkauf quasi größten zu
setzen
ob es jetzt zu sagen kartons sind oder
ob das ein geflecht allgemein ware ist
also handle da schon viel im shop und
ich schon sagen ich würde schon sagen
das ist sogar noch einen tick mehr
arbeit als mit dem video ja das ist für
mich ist das einen vollzeitjob und auf
anderen vollzeitjob daher gehen ganz
viele pops an die frau habe ich das
jetzt so gut gestellt ob sie wirklich
heftig heftig kann es immerhin die so
aufgenommen wir das nach aufnahme haben
wir über alte zeiten
unsere ersten videos entstand mit dem
iphone 6 sollten sich aber es war ganz
wichtig war das einfach sind jetzt hat
eine bessere quote von 6
angefangen beim iphone aber das ist ja
von einem handy bist raus in die welt
von zu hause in die mail heißt es ja so
ich habe jetzt hier die nudeln das ist
der türkischen reise nach türkischen
reis dazu die nudeln in butter
angebraten mutter ihr könnt ihr mich
hoch erhöhter schmerz butterschmalz
omega lecker und da gibt's jetzt man
reis dazu lothar giesler englische
bekennt dass kurz wasser rein so jetzt
habe ich hier wasser zu meinem reißen
geben und mein basic rezept bereits
verlinkt ich euch unten in der box was
im video was ich dann wieder nicht zeige
ist das was ich von handlungs mama
gelernt habe nämlich ras el amud rhein
zu tun
das ist noch mal so richtig
doch manchmal gucke mal rein ja deswegen
hat es sind auch der reise war so gernot
ein bisschen rein ich gebe dann noch ein
bisschen weiter und schmeckt das aber
ist ja auch ein bisschen gucken
aber was kann das ist auch so eine sehr
orientalische was ist noch viel also
marokkaner leben des volt also die
marokkanische küche ist voll mit ja und
und viele dachten in den ersten jahren
also wirklich sehr lange dass du
marokkaner wisst wie kommt das
eigentlich ich weiß nicht ich habe
glaube ich ein markantes gesicht
ja ich wollte die marokkaner ebel sich
schon sehr so vom erfolg von der optik
her und ich weiß nicht wieso aber ich
glaube ich dadurch dass ich aufgewachsen
bin habe ich das gericht eingegangen man
sagt ja auch wenn man viel mit dem mann
zusammen ist sieht man dem ähnlich wir
haben ja heute kein paar burka gezwungen
sah ich abgesprochen wenig sehen einfach
das einfach du oder bad ist also ja das
kommt die frage warum kriegen twitter
haben sie noch nicht einmal fertig haben
sagt 290 eine stand ich sag mal so rein
pietro lombardi kriegt ja auch mehr
kippt das denn weil die leute kennen
einfach was hat hat auch mal gips
getragen
das ist einfach so dass es also erst mal
ich finde es auch ganz cool und ich mag
käppis zu tragen habe ich auch schon
immer getragen schon seitdem ich zwei
disziplin seit ich genauso klingt wird
so richtig lecker ich mache jetzt hier
die hitze auch kommen jetzt immer auf
den topf an ich mache sehr stufe vier
von neun es aber beiseite
das ist wohl schwer was machen was
machen wir jetzt etwas passiert was
liebe den 30 da muss ich jetzt nichts
weiter machen was tue ich jetzt auf die
andere seite und dann können wir die
zwiebeln andere was hat das denn für ein
gericht ist das spezifische nein nein
einfach so was was lecker ist ein ich
muss das erstmal
eigentlich ja heute zu gast bin heute
eigentlich ja gar nicht am nächsten tag
dann wäre war der 29 super wetter man
sowas passiert unsere okay an klar sein
und da sich am dünnsten du dich nämlich
olivenöls darfst du bis 150 grad
erhitzen ja das ist klar das ist
kaltgepresstes wegen genau sehen und
knoblauch klar ja ich koche zum ersten
mal er ist somit ihr ja das stimmt
also mal packen war ja schon öfters aber
kocht doch einmal habe ich die tun sich
mit siege braucht ja eine ziemlich hatte
für das 2 ja ich hab echt zeit schon hat
der geworfen haben sich genauso ein
jahresrückblick machen mit dir wenn du
an den januar 2020 sagt sebastian
cheesecake heftig
also das war ein großer chor er schmeckt
auch richtig mega also ich glaub auch
weiß was ich das also das coole das ist
er geständig
mit ihr hat echt wirklich woche daran
gesessen doch gesagt wochen waren dort
tagelang nochmals ja seit 22 wochen
immer mal wieder zu aber du bist also du
sollst paar stunden rezepte probiert du
hast auch mehrere zu probieren
und bis das perfekte die gelungen ist
also ich fand auf jeden fall ein kuchen
das war einfach ein krasser heftiger
kuchen ja und wird seine rezeptur oder
sowieso mehr
also eins muss ich ja sagen wie
entstehen hypes indem man etwas populär
macht und wir haben diesen passus
extended türkei ja schon sehr bekannt
ist mit sicherheit auch in spanien wo er
herkommt aber das ist so würden nein in
istanbul wurde der gehalten und wir
haben denen dann so krass hier nach
deutschland gebracht ich sehe im
internet so viel auf so vielen blogs auf
youtube so viele videos die den gemacht
haben das ist einfach das wort kuchen
feuern wir noch nie gesehen überhaupt
nicht so wild dass auch erst als
minister backhaus verbot von jedem einen
weil
wir haben einen richtigen foto als m2
food blogs in istanbul gedreht die
sammlung im februar ist das online
gekommen
jetzt bringen wir rüber richtung februar
als wir dann nach dem wir in san
sebastian cheesecake gemacht haben und
gehalt haben veröffentlicht haben waren
wir dann wieder da und wie viele san
sebastián haben wir gegessen in 34 tagen
wo ich glaube die haben jeden tag drei
stück ich glaube die fünf stücke oder
sechs german slogan weg durch die
provinz ja und das war dann noch mal so
ein krasser verkleiden dann ist im
februar dann istanbul food blog online
gegangen da gab es ja da war von der
pandemie noch nicht so wirklich was zu
spüren da kam es gerade mal so groß
pankow es irgendwas passiert und so wir
waren noch in istanbul für 4 tage 3
bezogen die tage wie man das echt schön
wir haben davor warnt die kulturellen
ecken erkundet von istanbul dass man das
dritte mal dass das feuer im september
müssen wir kurzem bisschen gemacht ja
aber im februar haben wir dann gesagt
ich mache ist ein flop für euch das war
sogar zwei loks ich verlinke ich euch
und das war eine halbe stunde oder soja
und alle sind einfach als brücke ist
aber es gibt und auch so teuer sachen
und nicht nur einfach die die es schon
gibt also ja beides so mehr die haben
die kräfte auf sushi akw so gerne
probiert und die waren in einem rosa
café wo überall blut war so schön dass
wir sehr schöne achim habe ich meine
preis auch dazu gestanden die videos mit
sehr gelungen guckt ihr euch um gegen
mit wenn ihr das noch nicht gemacht habe
ja dann kamen wir im februar zurück aus
istanbul
also drauf du bist du alles genau wie
seinen weg und dann waren auf der messe
im märz geboren ist auf der rohe bau
genau in bochum mit mit markus von valea
griechen mittlerweile wirklich sehr
enger freund von uns treffen wir auch
mal privat sehr sehr liebe familie
christel ros größe geht drauf an
familien mal nach und da mir ganz viel
aus der community getroffen genauso viel
wir haben auch gute werkzeuge brachte
jeder etwas bekommen gebacken durst
mitgeholfen war richtig schön und auch
ein bisschen traurig weil da kam so die
welle nach deutschland
so langsam und danach die tage war es
recht recht recht schwierig irgendwann
merkt langsam dass wird ernst es ist
kein spaß mehr
ja und dann hat man das gemerkt haben
kamen locker und sonstigen dafür braucht
er nicht zu sagen ja inzwischen
versuchen den rückblick klar so
realistisch wie möglich zu halten
kommt mal ein bisschen schöne sachen zu
denken aber es kommt er jetzt also warum
also die lockdown hat bei uns auch uns
gezwungen doch zu hause bleiben und
dadurch haben wir auch mehr rezepte
entwickelt hier mehr videos gemacht
das paketgeschäft frage ist ja viel
größer gefahren wir die leute alle zu
hause in die wahl was kochen was banken
die lee dugard ressourcen zugemacht
haben wir quasi rezepte raus kann ohne
ende werden 34 videos am mittwochmittag
waren richtig aktion ist sehr aktiv auch
natürlich damit ihr so ein bisschen
futter hartem material was viele von
euch mussten dann auch zu hause gerne
hätte es ja ihre war dann ein großes
problem
ohne hebel rezepte und macht sich halt
immer so ein bisschen an
ja und dann mit dem lock down oder mit
der zeit kam er dann natürlich auch da
madame und das war ein sehr spezielles
ramadan also rekurs aber gib mir mal das
fleisch kommt jetzt auch schon mal ist
musste ich so scharf gebratenen sondern
wirklich so ein bisschen bis zum dünsten
also bewusst spricht
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt ein bisschen pause macht
weil ja weißt du gezeigt hat wozu laut
genau zwölf rundherum an gebürstet innen
noch rosa es gibt aber gleich eine soße
alles sagte malki ja was ist das für
eine tolle oma könne griff wochen war
ich mit meinem erbe stimmt ja ich liebe
handeln erwischte nicht nur mir sicher
dass
werden wir sicher dass wir richtig viele
von euch verkaufen wir sind alle kommt
am ramadan ihr müsst euch vorstellen ich
weiß habe nicht nur muslime in meiner
community in der community deshalb müsst
ihr euch vorstellen
ramadan ist dafür gemeinschaft für
familie freunde zusammen auch das fasten
brechen was war dieses jahr
ja das war ich sag mal jetzt so wie
jetzt weihnachten ist für die für die
christen was wahrscheinlich auch
schwierig weil wir uns deswegen konnte
ich das jetzt an heiligabend so gut
nachvollziehen genau weil dabei auch
einen lock down also wir haben dort
genau genauso und kunden ja ganz machen
so ja normalerweise ist das sowas
letzten jahr alle zwei drei tage zu
meiner familie zu deiner vergessen oder
die waren bei uns also diesmal was ja
gar nicht so wir haben ja ich glaube
zwei mal wieder eingeladen also am ende
einigten freybe habe es war einmal da
haben wir auch nicht und das war's so
normalerweise ist man immer zusammen
gerade der ramadan ist man nie alleine
weil die anderen das erste mal alleine
ist in eine einzelne haushalt du bist
immer noch mal mit freunden oder mit
vermieden doch mal ist einfach so das
war ja diesmal gar nicht so war sehr
traurig aber das ist halt so im rahmen
eines dafür da dass wenn du jemand sieht
der alleine ist dass er haye kommen
lassen und so diese gemeinschaft
gemeinschafts technologie von adobe
nicht
ja ich war nicht da war nicht da
deswegen jetzt hatten wir vom partei
deswegen habe ich auch zu den
christlichen zuschauern von uns redet
kann absolut verstehen das ist eine
schwere zeit aber dann zieht man die so
einmal durch und hoffen das bleibt ja
ich hoffe auch jahre gestellt kurz
gemüsebrühe noch mit rein
wir haben jetzt auch immer noch hohe
zahlen hier und ich weiß nicht wen
ramallah ist dieses jahr zehn tage
früher als letzte also quasi im april
hoffen wir dass es bis dahin ein
bisschen ruhiger wird ich glaube 2030
oder weiß ich nicht welches jahr nagelt
mich drauf fällt aber irgendwann dass
winter ist da und weihnachten zusammen
dann feiern ich gebe jetzt noch passt
dazu ich nehme ein fertiges ein gutes
fertiges pastor hier sitzt mit spinat
und käse ihr könnt auch eins nehmen mit
basilikum
ich kann das gemüse wo ich für dich
sowie die wüsten sollte mal ist dass
unsere gemüsebrühe aber an den kalender
monat sind wir noch nicht angekommen
also oder festo mit reiki ich mach da
doch johnny solche tabletten oder nun
täglich auf jeden fall kam ja dann auch
bei unserem online shop eine riesengroße
welle also wir haben wir kamen gar nicht
mehr will man mega überfordert aber es
war auch so ja ich glaube durch den
druck dann gab es auch viel mehr
bestimmen wir die leute draußen saßen ja
und die nachfrage uns natürlich größer
geworden wir sind auch mit den
zuschauern also mit der brille ja auch
sehr kraft also diesen kreis gestiegen
ja wir haben auf einmal dann einen
zuwachs von 80 bis 100 ohren gehabt
es ist ja klar dass dann auch die
nachfrage nach der puppen größere
carrier vor allem mehrere videos dann
genau es ist auch ganz natürlich weil
alles was ich zb meinem shop anbieter
das sind sachen die sind bewährt die
benutze ich ganz natürlich also ich bin
ich mach das jetzt nicht so dass ich auf
krampf irgendwas benutzen ihm ans
verkaufen möchte sondern das mach ich
das leid das natürliche prozesse und da
waren wir echt ein bisschen überfordert
ihr müsst euch vorstellen die hatten
angefangen hat das ganze sowieso vor
anfang april 2009 10 in deinem 30
quadratmeter jungen sind es kombis ein
bisschen kleiner gestürzt
er werde nur noch genutzt deswegen das
kind und das ist alles angefangen wir
hatten ein mitarbeiter kann griffen raus
als sehr sehr enger freunde auch die
us-ökonomen er war der erste kunden hört
euch bestimmt und ich weiß noch für
meine erste bestellung das war ein genie
finde dass dieses ganze begrüße die hat
glaube ich drei artikel bestellt und ich
sag's 45 minuten an diesem paket weil
ich sage ich mache das so dann mach ich
doch mal her da musste hätte klima noch
mal ab und nochmal grad also ich möchte
mich vollständig saßen da sind so kein
zimmer haben wir bestimmen reinbekommen
und wir selbst haben sie erstmal park
ist war eine so dass wir mitarbeiter
hatten also jetzt ein gehabt hat zum
zeitpunkt aber wir haben gar kein
mitarbeiter john key carter selbst mit
liebe das so verpackt und kiki das ist
nur eine kunde gewesen du hast du noch
hunderte von anderen kunden 40 minuten
habe ich dafür auch nicht so er ich gehe
es auf dieser zeit zwei wochen
ja auch weil das so als als anfang bei
hansa im kinderzimmer na und ja das
sieht gut aus folgte sich lieber kurz zu
ende
was soll dann ja und dann haben wir uns
irgendwo angebaut
wir machen es die 80 quadratmeter 85
vermieter in lager gemietet ein paar
monate
was war auch sehr sehr eng es wurde sehr
eng anfangs ging es noch aber dann war
die nachfrage schon mal größer wir sehen
uns mit den zuschauern gewachsen auch
und das sieht nachfragesog alles klar
wir müssen jetzt raus weil dann kam er
quasi das war alles noch das geht ende
mai anfang am ende april anfang mai
hatte schon im april also ich schon im
märz quasi sagen er will veränderung ja
so aber denke stark auf starke so dass
wir einfach gar keine zeit haben so geht
es jetzt um hört doch mal raus weil es
war viel zu irgendwie haben fahre
bestellt die war ausverkauft aber nichts
pakete war aber der ausverkauf das ging
gar nicht müssen jedes mal neu bestellen
kein leben gehalten und dann war auch
mal ein paar tage ist es ausverkauft das
wollen wir vermeiden so und auch die
versagen kosten sind immer größer
geworden ist es immer viel mehr geworden
und versandkosten zu sagen kartoffeln
karton ist wieder größer geworden und am
letzten tag als wir dann endlich ein
langer gefunden haben wo wir jetzt drin
sind am letzten tag einer zulegt ich
habe mir so ein tapeziertisch genommen
weil drinnen wandern unsere drei
mitarbeiter langeweile und co
ja das wollte selber werde ich habe
tapeziertisch genommen habe ich nach
draußen eine shell gott sei dank hat es
nicht geregnet hat draußen angefangen
pakete zu verpacken
eine andere mitarbeiter sollen ruf
gehabt aber niemand andere mitarbeiterin
hat mich sehr unterstützt liebe grüße
anfang mal an der stelle
dann habe ich den kofferraum geklappt
habe andere mitarbeiter zu verraten und
das ist echt verrückt dass ich sehen die
wir euch hat mir gezeigt haben wir
denken uns dann auch mal was denken die
leute erfahren wir haben sich selber
reingelegt haben einfach alles versucht
um euch schnell zu beliefern und damit
sind sie auch nicht unglücklich setzen
und dann unser land schreibt
hansa-keeper paket und dass das von uns
haben
und die herausforderung leute zu finden
mitarbeiter einzustellen rat finden mal
wir wollten wieder drei garten ja genau
und dann findet man auf die schnelle mal
so zählt stück bringt mal zehn
mitarbeiter man muss ja auch vertrauen
da sei nicht gerade ich das denn mein
baby unser baby ja wo ist dein baby das
nächste mal bist du schwanger mache auch
dazu hatte was mache ich am ende des
videos noch war für das nach politischen
und soja da sind dicker spiler hier also
fast übersieht ist ja haben wir kommen
zurück bekommt etwas zurück das jetzt
irgendwie geschafft wir haben wirklich
ein starkes team
falls ihr ich weiß nicht schaut euch das
video umgezogen das ist das ergebnis von
raad ich arbeite auf 800 wir was
erzählen noch vergrößert und haben dann
auch natürlich die mitarbeiterzahl um
das zehnfache also ist ja quasi 325
jahren zwischen reserve menschen mit
arbeit und ich danke ihnen ein filmen
von euch auch an diesen tagen jetzt
wieder mit so viel belastung so viel gas
zu geben da bin ich richtig richtig
stolz auf die kritik
ja und wir packen natürlich auch
teilweise noch selber haben sagte malki
geht auch so viel zu tun muss rezepte
endlich verstehen aber ich liebe es
zwischendurch mal in den shop zu gehen
meldet mit dem batzen bestellungen ich
gehe durch die regale und verpackte
pakete also landes spaß macht mache ich
das doch immer noch weiter ja das war
der main
das war nicht so der gesamte munition ja
und jetzt kommt der juni der juni war
wieder so davon alles ein bisschen
lockerer
die haben auch über liebhaber fliegen
wir den urlaub oder nicht auf stressige
monate hinter uns haben lange lange
überlegt im juni sind wir dann nicht
gefragt was an julians gemacht werden
videos gemacht werden wie das gedrehte
geschützt wie das genau waren auch mehr
oder videos dabei mit dem wir auch prinz
genannt sind
erdbeer saison richtig ausgenommen wird
das war schon in mir drehen
es gibt einen türkischen anspruch in der
causa also diese diese erdbeer rezepte
die ich im feuer nicht alle zeigen
konnte weil wir das nie verpasst haben
aber es ist ja alle nach gewusst was sie
richtig schön da eigentlich im juni ja
kummer bewahren
das war noch andere mal da und sie
hatten kein video mehr gehabt aber wir
mussten das video in fremont es am
monatsende haben lassen wir hier um 19
uhr
ja was wäre das war nachrichten 120 euro
und da haben wir das video gedreht für
den nächsten tag aber ich habe an dem
abend noch geschnitten und das kam
nächsten mal auch online sowie haben wir
hätten auf instagram hat dies bemerkt
und so etwas passiert es am nächsten tag
dann nachmittags im trend weil die leute
das haben sie so geschätzt was ich mir
da wirklich schweiß und blut verloren
haben an dem arm ja dass dieser
komischen das video sieg um die trends
und die sind bei transfers ich glaube
wir auf platz zwei oder drei männern
das wäre aber da da sie sagen wir wieder
wie wichtig eine community ist ohne die
bist du quasi ganz so viel haut stecken
und vorher eine steuer community auch
ein nein glaubt und vertraut und ja das
ist wahrscheinlich auch werden das ist
ja auch so wenn du den weg zurück ist
dann geben wir auch viel silber zurück
wenn du dir nicht über das bauhaus dann
hauen nicht übers ort ist ja doch sind
sie braucht da sind sie da und das ist
bei uns aber fair veröffentlich das
stimmt wenn ich brauche seid ihr da das
hat der hansa echt schön gesagt das ist
wirklich so und da kann ich mich auch
immer euch verlassen
und da kommen wir noch mal zum punkt das
kommt eigentlich also später aber weißt
du es mir auch aufgefallen ich
persönlich also man macht ja auch immer
so einen kleinen persönlichkeits wandel
oder dings durch mehr dass man sich
sogar ein bisschen ein bisschen
weiterentwickelt und ich hoffe dass das
tun wir auch mal die wollten wir auch
gemerkt dass ich irgendwann jetzt im
lauf der letzten monate richtig auf mehr
rausgekommen bin höre mich auch drauf
vor der kamera so fine day sage ich
schon was euch die ist eigentlich voll
hinter der kamera ich schwör's euch die
ist richtig lust ja ich habe kamera ist
hier manchmal nicht lustig ja also es
ist zu steil und wie ist nenne mal wieso
bist du so da ist möglich so also krieg
ist manchmal echt gewesen vor der kamera
aber mit 30 mehr
also ich weiß nicht wovon paar monaten
hat es angefangen ich habe viele
blockaden abgelegt und konnte einfach so
richtig einfach verrückt bin ich glaube
die hat ein bisschen schafe bei einem
akw
doch die videos nicht in deine man
einfach ja der ganze klub malen macht
einfach sein was du selbst dass es viel
lustiger du selbst wirst es ist auch
viel authentischer dass du es bist und
du hast doch gemacht ja für mich auch
ganz cool will und dienten unter einem
video oder mehrere bürger da bekomme ich
ja auch feedback von euch und viele
seiner loki und so ich kann die
kommentare einblenden was er mir dann so
ein feedback zurückgibt und das zeigt
mir nur ob jetzt bin ich an diesem punkt
kann endlich einfach frei schnauze sein
sonst haben wir auch die videos er die
ihre fonds straight schritt für schritt
für schritt
ich will ich bin kein fan davon ein
video unnötig in die länge zu ziehen und
besonders albern das ganze auf krampf zu
strecken aber wenn ich das mache ich und
du machst das also ich finde auch
generell das haben sie auch immer
dazugehört und und das wird auch immer
so bleiben dass hamza das kitchen von
cookies kitchen ist skoda grüße
karosserie smith im juli juli sind wir
ja geflogen nach santorini und das war
wirklich so der erste und mein gott
dieser erste entspannungsurlaub
machthabers an bevor er von reals also
hast also die das ist jetzt schon wissen
das weiß niemand
das ist auch gar nicht gesagt ja so
jetzt kommt auf die hauses hinzu
ja wir waren ja eigentlich aus wie
heute zur ernte von der hans krämer das
anfang august wenn es dann so ok alles
klar wie fliegen das training von da aus
legen wir danach ist griechenland türkei
ist nicht weiter so und dann also ich
mache urlaub und danach fliegen wir
quasi zur arbeit weiter so das sollte
eigentlich so geplant sagt wir haben die
flüge buchen zum glück haben wir eine
vision gehabt also richtung weil die
eltern sich doch für schwung und woche
ja um eine woche hat nämlich schon genau
und dann sind wir doch nach hause
geflogen und von dort aus dann quasi
eine woche später in die türkei
genau da wo ich hin muss das weiß
niemand das wird echt niemanden und wir
hatten auch viel panik und so weil das
hat sich total gekreuzt an turin war
schon gebucht werden aber jederzeit
unseren urlaub abgesagt
für die haselnuss ernte sag ich mal und
auch bis dato wusste auch niemand dass
für eine haselnuss creme rausnehmen weiß
müssen obwohl die im januar schon
geplant war
und dann wussten wir es quasi also ich
bin auf instagram allerdings wenig
folgen jeden tag mache ich story sehen
tag nehme ich euch durch meinen tag
nicht ich habe niemals fünf tage noch
verzichten können wo ist sie auf einmal
ich kann das gar nicht rein wollen ja
das ist ja auch dann zu der zeit es war
innovativ man die wieder natürlich alles
wieder ruhiger geworden und sind
schuldig sein warum warum ja es ist ja
auch ich sag mal so wir sind ja urlaub
geflogen ist hat dieser mann der
kommentar einer wirklich komplett
alleine das haus war kommt für uns haben
auch viel danach fragt holzhaus war
flüchtlings ist ja spricht allerdings
dass man aber wir wollen heute und sie
war nicht im hotel wir haben keinen
druck gemacht weil wir haben einfach
unser angebot hat ja auch unser eigenes
häuschen gehabt und mir war das teil
abgeschaltet weil so ein hotel oder
gemacht haben wer ist für uns also
meinung nach auch nicht gerade gut
gewesen aber wir haben uns bewusst dafür
entschieden und natürlich wollen wir den
leuten und sagen okay hier fliegen
täglich unter urlaub zu machen auch wie
klingt auch wenn quasi für euch diese
man also eine vorbildfunktion
also ich bin ganz ehrlich ich weiß kann
ich überhaupt so ehrlich sein soll
gerade aber ich muss komisches
deutschland ist aber ich glaube wären
wir nicht in der öffentlichkeit wenn wir
einfach nur kicken und haben sehr dass
verheiratete ehepaar das nichts für
social media mut hat und ich so also ich
bin entwickelt auch körperlich echt muss
ich sagen jetzt zumindest ein bisschen
ausgelaufen kaputt das gebe ich auch
ehrlich zu durchlaufen
ich wäre
eiskalt weggeflogen nicht einfach allein
um ein bisschen runter zu kommen habe
ich hier natürlich aber wenn man diese
vorbildfunktion und deswegen verzichten
wir darauf das ist ganz klar dass ich
kann das auch nicht machen das klingt
das stimmt aber jetzt voll kurve nicht
weil die leute denken so ok privat ist
gemacht jetzt aber ich war wirklich so
ist dann ist man kein perfekter blau und
das ist das habe ich aber auch gut dass
du ich hab ich habe ja auch darüber
geredet werden diese jetzt weggeflogen
hat er dich aber du hast noch wird es
gibt eine überlieferung wichtig ich
möchte nicht nur etliche verschiedene
aber für eine lesung irgendwo gesagt
wird präsente sollte das land nicht
verlassen oder was sollte sein stadt
nicht verlassen wenn eine pandemie ja
man sollte man hat ist quasi selber auch
in der fachlich schutz der eigenen
befürchten unter anderem dass man sich
einfach nicht fortbewegt wenn du gerade
so ein ausnahmezustand
und da kommen jetzt auf dem thema das
wissen auch die wechsel erfolgt auf
install noch mal wieder dass wir auch
gern mit gerne das war dann aber eher
ein bisschen später richtung
september/oktober wo wir dann zur ernte
der oliven nach palästina fliegen
wollten mit dem papa das haben wir
komplett in den sand gesetzt weil
erstens ist es generell schwierig da
reinzukommen israel und so und dann noch
die pandemie on top damit dass dann mega
und verantwortlich müsst euch vorstellen
so ich bin ich komme aus palästina
ursprünglich so und ich habe deutsche
passt zwar schon mal christina und ich
sei ja ich war ja eine grenze von jordan
und dann saß ich da stundenlang mit
meiner schwägerin nichte beim bruder
meine schwester und ich haben uns echt
schikaniert und und echt uns die wollen
einfach die wollten dass rauskitzeln
damit wir irgendwie fehler machen damit
sie nicht reinkommen so und ich weiß
auch selber also mein vater aber auch
selber schon da der ist auch eine
führung der kam aber nicht rein er war
sogar also ich sag mal wie gefängnis
aber der kam halt nicht durch und das
war das problem wo ich sage okay dass
wir dann jetzt durch die panne wie
sowieso schwierig und dann auch mit
meinem vater
ich hätte ihn gerne gerne gerne
mitgenommen weil er war noch nie
interessiert thema vier oder fünf jahren
diese und das ist das wo ich mich
richtig gefreut hätte aber das war halt
einfach nicht möglich vielleicht ja im
nächsten jahr mal gucken ob ich hoffe
ja das war jetzt kurz offtopic aber
zurück zur haselnuss creme also dass man
wirklich so die schönsten tage die ich
hier erleben durfte sich mit dir auf so
emotional dass seine schönsten tage oder
muss sagen ich habe das video kann ja
vor kurzem online und ich muss sagen das
ist das schönste was ich je gemacht habe
muss ich mich gestellt habe dass er
selber so viele emotionen drin also von
der ernte bis hin zum moment wo du die
haselnuss und das war einfach richtig
also du bist so vorstellt so du hast
einfach eine eigene asus creme ja das
ist einfach krank das ist so mahler
weise ist man das so ein anderer
hersteller am liebsten morgens oder
abends je nachdem
und dann kommst du andere steht also das
hängt auch geht das ist ja das kann
wir saßen da warten müsst ihr euch
vorstellen wir saßen war stundenlang wir
drücken und kann man gar nicht noch
irgendwie noch mit milch so zu arbeiten
und das trasse ist wirklich das ist so
eine haselnuss creme da die gibt's
einfach nur ums die gibt es neben
windows partition die leute jetzt sagen
würde das ist doch von der und der firma
also sagen von durchsagen gemacht dass
hersteller die gibt es auch vor folgen
ja dann probiert doch mal die krebse
probiert doch mal rein
die creme zu bekommen selbst wenn ich
eine creme mit 33 prozent findet ihr
werdet nicht den geschmack haben wir den
idealen überhaupt nicht aber so wir
haben die rezeptur auch so geändert also
da sind so feinheiten wurde die 8,48
geachtet haben von den zuckergehalt bis
zu cremigkeit bis zu kokosöl drin ist so
vieles und unterteil voran welche herzen
ist so kommen wären sie einmal gerüstet
was schon mega ist manchmal gar nicht so
genau wenn sie doppelt größte pause hast
du noch darauf ein löffelchen also ohne
spaß ich schwöre ich habe das jetzt
wirklich ungelogen ich glaube zehn
freunden geben und alle zehn freunde
haben sie mal kanzlerin die haben
einfach ja man kann es ja ich habe es
auch einmal bis einlass 19 scheint
gelaufen oder nicht mal so % nachricht
noch extrem ich das ist zum wohle sind
[Musik]
du kannst auch löffel weiß sowieso weil
es nichts es ist nicht so dass das habe
ich nicht so richtig es verteilt sich
das ist so eine schöne sachen hast du
klein oder du denkst du schießt jetzt
überall ob ich hast du das nicht obwohl
ich ein riesen lob von anderen krebs du
dich niemals um diesen löffel ich hätte
wissen was ich komplett gerissen damit
naja das war unser baby unser projekt 20
das window wachsen das wird noch wachsen
ja es hat sicherlich das ganze jahr
gestreckt und im august also da waren
wir da haben wir es euch erzählt und
jetzt vor kurzem kam es wie das online
weil wir hatten auch angst ist wieder
online zu stellen dass das recht schnell
ausverkauft ist die erste ladung war
nach zwei stunden ausverkauft und das
tut mir leid das ist nichts worauf ich
stolz bin ist über die gameserver ich
habe mega schuldgefühle auch den außer
euch gegenüber dass nicht jeder was
abbekommen hat aber in der zweiten haben
wir das video raus zeigen euch die volle
transparenz ist schon gerade mir auch
ein bild dazu wir brauchen deutschen auf
dem weg genau so genug für hause können
wir nah genug bewegt also 2020 da muss
ich der kann die hasel dass sie so
unserem gericht ich lass das jetzt so
ein bisschen köcheln dann gebe ich
einfach mein gott
oktober verlangen gestellt obwohl ich
habe jetzt tiefgekühlten spiel nach ihr
könnt rammstein haben die mücken auch
normalen spielen
ich bin aber ich glaube ich auch viel
eisen drin bist raus berichtet teamwork
hier sexy super so eine clique doch die
musiker naseputzen ja dann hast du das
tust ja ja das war halt so der der
aufguss anfang august war das und im
august kam dann auch endlich weil das
sind alles dinge die hier nicht sehe
diesem hintergrund laufen im august kam
dann mein eigener café endlich an das
ist nur restaurant täglich kann fenster
quasi unter kuckucksuhr ist 33 ja so ein
kaffeegenießer bin und ich keinen kaffee
gefunden habt ihr mir zu 100 prozent
gefällt dachte ich mir ich lasse meinen
eigenen kaffee rösten und das kann auch
bei euch sehr gut
so wie wir noch mal was wir werden auch
vor ort machen films gerüstet wird genau
und er danke ich euch auch für das
vertrauen wenn ich immer in der story
sehe wie so ein neuer kaffee glück
genießt er da freue ich mich und im
august an der auch bei der produktion
unseres shuttles dazu kommt auch bei dem
video das mega interessiert also das ist
heft ist wie lange es braucht eine
flasche zu finden ja was ich dort
vertreibt dieses kalt gepresst und
langsam ist also je langsamer abriss
desto besser ist das internet oft
kaltgepresste öle die werden aber
relativ schnell kalt doch sehr freuen
und special folgen aber dort braucht ein
bisschen finger respawn der letzten
szenen geschrieben ist gern begründet
warum unser schwarzkümmelöl so günstig
ist trotz der ganzen benefits trotz der
ganzen news in der hohen qualität die
wir haben und ganz ehrlich sie ein
einzige begründung ist dass dem markt
gerecht sein müssen das produkt ist
eigentlich viel mehr wert aber wir
müssen natürlich auch gucken was die
preise am markt sind und youtube haben
immer direkt zu diesen stempel 8,4 die
klatsche ihren namen drauf und macht es
direkt tore aber so ist das gar nicht
mit auch mit da sind diskret also darf
wieder mit denen wir nicht reich aber
das ist mir hat's projekt so unsere
preise sind auch echt gut geraten muss
ich sagen also wir haben wir beachten
die auf dem markt das ist ja nicht so
dass wir auch noch den preis
wir gucken dann druckt dann um im
taschen da war 34 euro drauf das ist ja
nicht nee nee dann müssen wir auch
gucken was nur was halt so
ja ja und das problem ist dann kommen so
riesen wie amazon die systematisch
einfach gucken in anderen online shops
des briten die für preis an wir
unterbieten das egal ob vereins denn
daran gewinn machen ja ich meine es gibt
ja auch es gibt ja auch andere quasi
kleine supermärkte momentan ich merkte
sie haben ja auch die preise die sind ja
auch so tief die machen ja kein gewinner
nicht die machen das einfach nur so
damit kommen ja ja damit er das hat er
auch ist und im september was ist
passiert im september passiert also ich
muss sagen im september waren wir nur zu
haus und haben uns ein bisschen auf die
winter auf die weihnachtssaison
vorbereitet weil wollten wir haben uns
zum ziel ist wirklich so viele rezepte
wie möglich zu liefern auch drei rezepte
die vorfreude war im september schon
geplant weil
wir mussten halt zusehen dass wir neben
den ganzen anderen aufgaben auch der
geräte selber auch schon fix geplant
also kaum neues format ist gemacht haben
ja richtig die team ico adresse
eigentlich als krimis mit dem jump euro
angefragt einlagen und dann kam
irgendwann selbst wahrscheinlich konnte
keine weiteren gäste einladen ja auf
jeden fall im september ist eigentlich
nicht viel passiert außer dass wir
wirklich das gemacht haben was er machen
videos die richterin und wieder mal wird
dort immer sehr viel gemacht wenn man
sich viel gearbeitet ist es ja auch
nicht so dass wir jetzt nur die trainer
so ist es nicht diese kleinen dinge
jeden tag abgearbeitet wir haben genau
das sind viele sachen zum beispiel war
auch im september ganz stark was ihr
seht es vielleicht schon im hintergrund
vielleicht auch nicht bin noch nicht so
kraft auf einiger musste aber unsere
unsere eigentlichen gewürze zum beispiel
es gibt bei gewürzen einfach so krasse
unterschiede es werden gewürze gestreckt
gefärbt das glaubt ihr gar nicht und da
habe ich gedacht wenn ich schon die
möglichkeit habt und auch kochen eines
meiner leidenschaften ist dann machen
wir unsere eigene nun haben wir sogar
eigene gewürzmischungen mit dem jetzt
mit hakuna matata mit der ihr mit der
gewürzmischung könnt ihr eure kartoffeln
auftakt im rollout express im bollywood
express genau für indische gerichte
gemüsebrühe das gemüse und und
gemüsebrühe hab ich da rein macht da
habe ich auch also ich hab mir einfach
gedacht hey das fehlt das muss sein
einfach das muss einfach seinen eigenen
gewürzte das macht spaß so entwickeln
wie hinzustellen und zu sitzen und über
den bosporus wäre jetzt cool also was
wird bewusst was wäre wohl wo ich hier
in der schiller und das ist ja das coole
dadurch dass man halt auch die community
hat und das interesse von euch auch das
videospiel thema baklava also back dabei
ist auch 1 1 doch ganz ehrlich leute
werden damit nicht reich aber ich will
sie so lange es geht noch essen können
und sie sollen so lange es geht noch
produziert werden und daher freue ich
mich wenn ihr interesse habt und es hat
mir immer klammer zum spiel zu mama dann
veröffentlicht quasi die waren innerhalb
von ein paar stunden
deshalb ist das ergebnis so wie das von
april und dann jetzt wir haben es
geschafft sie jetzt noch mal zur
etablierung nochmal in den bestand auch
dieses jetzt quasi immer fürs drin also
das ist auch so ein politischen berichte
ja was auch nichts neues also wir achten
auch darauf wie wir haben es gibt es
nichts süßes ja gerade beim klang ist es
so du benimmst in die hand und dann
klebt alles läuft die den zuckersirup
runter ja und das ist seit traditionelle
handarbeiten klar sofern aber da kommt
auch ein video zu 100 pro jahr dazu
machen da wird doch zeigen also da ist
dieses vorgehen das war claudia witt per
hand wirklich so gedreht dass ich stand
da ich habe nicht geschehen
ich habe mich geschämt der mann und die
frau dass männer und frauen die das
machen teilweise auch aus syrien
die drehen was peer hahn und alle eines
heftig leute das ist heftig aber da
sieht man wie viel liebe auch in so
einem druck stück das ist echte
handarbeit
ich habe jetzt zum beispiel auch in
meinem backt er weiß auch dass pro tag
drin das durchgehen dass ich gerne
benutze und kein anderes ich wollte auch
keine andere marke oder firma weil ich
genau weiß nur die haben diese rezeptur
die mir gefällt und das ist jetzt auch
im reis drin weil ich mich daran
erinnert dass man guckt ob der gar ist
so man rises gar ich was kennt mich eine
kamera noch sieht da sich aber der rest
ist gibt es on top auch noch mal ein
bisschen butter drauf und haben sie ja
mein gast bis nach ein paar fragen
stellen
du darfst auf dem server ist was soll
meine frau da rede ich nicht umgehen
auch eine frau guck mal du bist doch 14
verheiratet
nur fragt schon sooo süß herkomme
gemacht es ist doch irgendwo keine
normale ehe oder ich hätte auch nicht
also ich finds auch nicht normal dass
man da mal mit seiner frau shoppen gehen
und dann leute mich ansprechen
[Musik]
ich hab mal so viel freundschaft so
halte ich meine freunde und cousinen und
so sein ist doch immer so ich besonders
zuschauer und dann machst du so heidi
geht es dir du weißt ja das ist doch
wirklich manchmal weiß ich gleich ob die
wirklich kindes oder das ein zuschauer
ist das kann ja manchmal nicht
unterscheiden
wie ist es für dich aber du bist doch
auch erkannt oder ich werde auch
tatsächlich auch erkannt ja ich will ja
sogar teilweise hat meine stimme ja
nicht immer so toll und man das draußen
ich glaube dass das ist ja das was ich
aber wollte diese markenzeichen dieses
capital betrage klar jetzt ist der kies
kitchen drauf ist es noch ein verleger
aber ähnliche käppi trage dann ist es
halt das ist so man kann das zeichen mal
werden es stehen aber es hat mich auch
gerne als letzten surfen halbes jahr den
bürgern angesprochen und gesagt bist du
ich habe es ja und ich habe so richtige
sketchen kph nicht so nahe wie kommst du
darauf doch nicht so schnell wie kommst
du darauf so und das ist auch mein logos
oder doch ist ja klar ich könnte mir
aber das ist so ja also wie es oft
erkannt ich werde auch auf der kann aber
es ist mittlerweile ist es schon wie
normal geworden
ich weiß noch als wir das erste mal
erkannt worden essen in mekka platz hat
in seiner angesprochen
bist du nicht geschehe unter den nicht
wirklich und haben sofort geht das
besser geworden so einheitlich erkannt
ja man hat sich halt so vollmer hat sich
so gedacht
sie kennt mich einfach wie ein video das
ist echt richtig arbeiten muss war sagen
also ich hab ich habe lange ich war
lange auch nicht da draußen ja dagegen
diese ganze geschichte so und ich weiß
gar nicht wie das jetzt auswirken hat
weil jetzt mehr als doppelt so lange
nicht mehr unterwegs war ist noch
doppelt so groß dass jetzt eigentlich
noch mehr leute kennen ich habe keine
ahnung das ist aber das ist schon
irgendwie normal geworden ist also nicht
ja aber ich muss sagen ich schön weil
wir sehen dann auch wer ihr seid das
zeigt doch immer wieder
ich sehe dann endlich mal gesichter ihr
kind meinen geschichten haben sie es in
und auswendig
aber wir wissen nicht wer ihr seid quasi
was ich schön finde da muss ich prozent
geben auch wenn das ist schade ist aber
viele sagen und kiki sehen geht dir du
bist ein echter ja ja ja ich glaube das
ist diese instagram welt diese filter
und festigung und blabla hast du nicht
gesehen und ich glaube viele haben dann
auch anderen zweimal gesehen und sie
dann einfach erschrocken sind dass sie
so aus das glaube ich aber dass ich
nervig dass manchmal haben sie zuweilen
öffentlich weil haben sie auch da kannst
du nichts
also ganz ehrlich manchmal würde ich
einfach sagen wenn ich meinen freunden
bin jetzt hört sich immer gut zu meiner
freunde da will ich einfach noch harmlos
sein so und dann komme ich dann sehe ich
die mal nach einem monat wieder ein wiki
leaks kitsch na du meinst aber selbst
wenn du mit deinen freunden
dadurch einfach nur abschalten dadurch
angekommen zu sein der alte hamza und
nicht dieser haben so von kies kitchen
oder andere thema abonnenten zuschauer
shop dies dass und denkst du so er okay
das könnte man muss nicht durchkommen so
was schon mal abschalten war gerade mein
freund ist man ja verquatschen private
sachen quatsch so es muss nicht immer
alles um die arbeit so klar es ist
unsere hobby geworden aber es ist auch
tages- und arbeit und manchmal einfach
abschalten das ist das was mich nur
nervt sagt weil auch wenn ich mal
freunde sie die sportlich gesehen ist es
ja auch so
immer wenn frau ja ich bin leider auf
geht's mir gar nicht aber mir geht's
darum gesamten wollen über das thema
klar und ich möchte nicht jedes mal das
gleiche thema durchkommen ja ja ich
glaube dass die folge feiern uns aber
trotzdem gibt's ja auch leute die in
deinem umfeld die das nicht feiern
leistung oder dieses somit lächerliche
ziehen oder aber sonst auf 24 30 muss
sagen anfangs echt viele berichtet auch
freunde
naja kann ich bestätigen ihr schweine
etwas belächelt ist wirklich so also
mich belächelt und daher guck mal hier
die machen jetzt gerade mache youtube
habe also und irgendwann kam dieser
knackpunkt ich glaube da kam auch durch
den durch die kooperation mit kaufen
da haben sie uns ernst genommen der
warme sonne also ewig und haben sie
einen koffer zusammen das ist nicht das
ist jetzt nicht einfach nur youtuber das
ist krank so auf einmal kiki ist einfach
das gesicht also das bak gesicht von
koffer die sie bei creed verkäufe und
das ist dann so daneben eine ernste also
der hamza macht jetzt die videos wir
kaufen auch den koffern canal du bist
natürlich auch ernster genommen aber
vorher war das so es ist schade dass
dies erst dann ja dann gesehen aber
immer sehr mit dem erfolg kommen auf
einmal dann die zugeschnitten das ist
traurig aber das ist so ich hab ich habe
meine frau erzählt ich habe mal vor vier
jahren ehe von dreieinhalb ist dazu eine
halbe seite youtube gemacht haben
vielleicht 2000 abonnenten weiß ich
nicht
da habe ich auch einer freundin gesagt
immer noch eine sehr gute bei einer
meiner besten freunde
sie haben ich würde schon mal gerne
selbstständig damit sein und hatte
einfach zu lachen und ich hatte unsere
mitgelacht so einer
das ist selbst ein hobby zum beruf
geworden und man muss auch sagen wir
sinken jetzt auch nicht in diesem beruf
so ein so dass wir sagen ey wir müssen
jetzt mit allem geld machen
wir haben auch so viele kooperationen er
glaubt mehr leute da sind krasse suchen
gespielt wir haben es abgelehnt habe
wir lehnen eigentlich wöchentlich
abgewöhnt ab und manchmal komme ich die
krassen kooperation ganz ehrlich damit
kann man sich schon ein kleines häuschen
bauen und das lehnen wir dann auch ab
weil es einfach nicht passt oder nicht
auf jeden fall dass man muss auch sagen
ich habe auch
12 mal beiseite lässt so einfach machen
und dann hast kannst du uns schwer sein
ein geht nicht wenn ich dahinter stehen
richtung her da sage ich okay dann
machen wir das nicht so klar manchmal
ist das gilt sogar das ist viel sonne
aber das ist ja wir verkaufen nicht
jetzt unsere seele für diese kooperation
absolut nicht richtig vorstellen wie
hätten für einen satz den wir einfach
und du wirst eingebunden hätten das ist
krank einfach einsatz werden dass wir
mehrere tausend euro ja ein nein bloß
ein satz den man einbinden musste in ein
video hinter diesem satz ich aber nicht
stand und dass es wäre euch gewünscht an
ich bin ganz ehrlich es würde euch nicht
aufgespürt niemanden die brauchwassers
wäre euch nicht ausgefallen
also ich wäre dafür ein ganz normales
rezept video und wir werden ein paar
tausend euro auf dem konto
aber wir haben abgelehnt weil es einfach
ich kann abends nicht stocken ich will
also wenn ich kann in russland das wäre
quasi die schleichwerbung im august
seiner wer sucht ja wir wollen abends
noch in ruhe ohne bauchschmerzen
schlafen gehen können und ohne daran zu
denken ist also ich war einfach nur
gutes event le mans nix nix essen
schlecht ist aber ich glaube das ist
auch so ein bisschen das geheimnis
unseres erfolgs dass wir nicht jede
kooperation nämlich nicht auch gesagt ja
so ist instagram lebt ja auch von diesen
rabatt codes unserer shop lebt auch von
habe als coaches ganz normal aber wir
haben halt ab um zusammen also quasi
alle 2000 heute mal jeden trainer ja das
10 prozent rabatt weise ich war ja
unsere margen sind nicht so wir mit
verlassen meine produkte zu 98 prozent
in deutschland produzieren und da sind
da kostet dann eben mal so eine winkel
paletten ich zwar um einkauft der masse
die fünfmal so viel dafür solltet ihr
also kaufte die einmal und nie wieder
das ist für mich ganz ehrlich eigentlich
so wirtschaftlich gesehen für uns
schlecht geschlossen wenn wenn ich so
ein richtiger gericht die geschäftsfrau
wäre oder dem geschäftsmann wie seine
holen jetzt was das nicht ein leben lang
hält verkaufen das ist echt gern das ist
doch nicht der erfolg war die leute
haben vertrauen in sie weil sie wissen
dass die polizei gut sind und ich sag
mal jetzt schon gleich mal uns jetzt mit
anderen
influenza ling nicht wie wert auf ihre
eigene qualität auf ihre eigene
produktion da ist mir schon einige aber
einige auch wiederum nicht
und dann hat man dieses gefühl du kaufst
etwas und dann ist es dann auch eine
woche kaputten server oder vielleicht
ein halbes egger wird kann ja auch etwas
vertrauen ja auch weg oder sie qualität
ist einfach nicht so gut genau und dann
bis jetzt vertrauen verlegt und dann ist
es vertrauen friends erregt so ja wenn
man einmal in tasche von einem freund
war auch wenn das wort sich aber
enttäuscht wird dann werden alle über
einen kamm geschert habe ich das gefühl
das ist aber so nah ist leider so wie
das denn irgendwas was du jemals in
deiner instagram zeuge teilte ist was du
richtig bereust du hast dich richtig
berühmt oder nicht richtig was du
einfach bereits ja also wir haben wir
also spendenaktion ich also ich sag mal
so ich mache das ist sehr sehr
ungewöhnlich auch jeden tag leute an und
sich natürlich auch ja und da kann es
mal aktionen darauf sehr sehr bereut
weil ich nachher kam was raus was nicht
richtig war oder weil ich halt ein
bisschen gemogelt hat und das habe ich
sehr bereut
deswegen mache ich das prinzip nicht
mehr man kann das einfach nicht mehr 100
prozent immer beweisen
dafür gibt's aber auch große
spendenorganisationen könnte auch
irgendwann selber sondern ein bisschen
machen ja eine stiftung oder sowas
natürlich auch ganz grün
vielleicht haben wir den grundstein
gelegt weil das find ich auch schon also
dann hat man wirklich glaube ich auch
vertrauen wenn wir das auch wichtige
hände abgeben wir werden quasi mit
unserem namen steht aber hier noch
indirekt eine operation arbeiten dass es
auch wirklich ankommt das geld aber das
ist so eine situation gewesen tages
bereit
deswegen mache ich das auch gar nicht
mehr es seit ich kenne die person
ich kenne personen davon gab es auch
einen fall da hab ich auch geteilt weil
sie es kommt auf jeden fall aber so nach
sami mich immer drei vier ecken hatte
ich gar nicht da ist auch viel
verantwortung drin und wenn man das dann
missbrauchte das ist sehr schade
weißt du was nicht viele fragen
tagtäglich jeden tag und das mehrmals
also wirklich auch wenn ein neues video
kommen 5 kommentare mindest bist du
schwanger
nein ich natürlich bisschen schwanger
und das schlimmste also es ist okay ich
bin immer so menschlich ist es auch
negativ ich habe zu viel empathie für
die leute ich denke man das nicht so
manche sind so die schreiben gibt es zu
du bist schwanger ich sehe es doch muss
man muss man immer das war niemals ein
also wirklich bald weiß ja also ich habe
das so ein video gemacht
ich glaube anfang des jahres oder das
ist ja ein video zum waschen insider tv
ich hatte darüber geredet weil das ist
mir echt auf senke gang weil so vieles
geschrieben haben deutsche erklärt also
jetzt abgesehen von tieren es gibt
vielleicht auch andere leute das habe
ich auch gesagt es gibt auch relativ sie
sind die wohnfläche werden und es klappt
dann und dann jetzt zu sagen wie diese
keine instanz oder sind keine bürgerin
stella ganz irgendwas also und dann
kommt dann die frage von freunden oder
familienmitgliedern die versuchen das
aber ich sagen es natürlich fangen ja ja
versuchen es aber es klappt nicht so das
frisst dich doch weil es damals ja das
ist wirklich voll verletzten sie ja ich
versuche aber auch sehr schnell machen
so du du wirst dich stellen damit kaputt
gehen und ich bin mir sicher dass viele
psychisch der 100 prozentig und das ist
noch ein druck kam und das erst recht
nicht funktionieren und muss sagen es
gibt auch leute die halt ein bisschen
zucker dann ist es halt so da muss man
nicht direkt auf diese schwanger schiene
kommt schwanken denn gerade so überall
gehalt auf youtube instagram ja wenn man
erst trend bestehen nur aus
schwangerschafts verkündungen oder aber
ich muss echt sagen will nur menschen
ich habe so ein dickes fell mit den
jahren bekommen also ich mach mir
überhaupt nichts draußen dann aber im
letzten zeit nur so gedacht hardcore wie
wieviel
also wie viele leute das wirklich
schreiben also da ist und keinen moment
wo ich echt genervt war aber wohl sagen
hat ist auch so
also wenn wir nicht gleich zuletzt sie
hat doch gar nicht zugenommen oder gar
nicht genau was ich hier gar nicht um
die fragen haben also die waage sagt was
andere kontakte die waage kaum 60 kg
wurde vom 6 nein also ich bin ja soo
menschen der also ganz ehrlich sagen
könnte sowieso wegschmeißen ihr müsst
euch in einem körper wohlfühlen wenn ihr
euch wohl fühlt dann tut war es dann
erhebt euch gesünder dann geht ein
bisschen öfter laufen oder so aber in
diese schwangerschaft also es ist ja
nicht nur diesem fall schwangerschafts
vermutung sondern richtig diese
behauptung ist jetzt sein kann auch so
ich weiß nicht ob der hübsche warum ist
aber ich denke schon dass ich mich immer
wieder räume ist geschehen
die straße ist also da kannst du schon
da sein dass du mich so ist ein ich aber
wirklich dagegen sage ich nichts wissen
will ist total liebe leute die schicke
ich will nichts mehr treten aber
bestrahlt irgendwie anlauf seine augen
blicken kann ich sagen immer wirklich
wenn du schwanger bist du das auch also
da wirst du irgendwas sagen verraten so
und dann müssen wir keine chance haben
die einfach erraten wollen und einfach
jetzt darauf dass sie ich gehe davon aus
weil wir jetzt die straße schon das
könnte mit ihrem freund besprechen aber
das musst du dir den ich ihr müsst euch
vorstellen
ich bin ich bin eine frau natürlich
möchte ich irgendwann kinder endlich
bauen kinder und und zwar gab es viele
ist doch klar als würde ich nur ein
also es kommt eh alles zu seiner zeit
und wir haben im moment einfach nicht so
viel last auf unseren schultern dass so
viele menschen die bei uns arbeiten die
möchten am ende des monats den
kühlschrank füllen die meisten am ende
ist man den kühlschrank und ich kann
jetzt nicht einfach mit der
kinderplanung anfangen was passiert denn
dann also ich kann ja nicht irgendwie
dann die ganzen liga total weiter videos
drehen und so ich muss ich muss das mal
richtig kann man jetzt auch super nanny
ich sage ganz ehrlich was ich hab auch
von vielen erfahren dass die probleme
hatten
während der schwangerschaft erstes darf
man hoffen ja die zwei jahre haben auch
noch einige das kind verloren ging wegen
dem scheiß ist ja noch so dass haben
wirklich viel glück und ich kenne ich
eine bekannte von uns und ich bekenne
die ist am ende vor dem komma genannt
ihr das kind feuer machen dort ist ein
cooler gelangen also darf nicht
unterschätzen nein also da muss man echt
mal abwägen und das problem ist doch bei
uns ist ja selbst wenn es jetzt so weit
kommt ihre du willst ja auch nicht
gerade seine geschützt sich auch bei den
eltern und ich wir sehen uns unsere
eltern ja diesem jahr fast gar nicht so
vielleicht einmal in zwei wochen
es ist gar nicht so könnt ihr die auch
ich mich schützen wollen sowie sind auch
dann da wenn überhaupt und soll es gar
nicht was mache ich dann werde ich
irgendwann muss auch noch die kinder
aufpassen sollen wir drehen
ich drehe ich filme dich du bist hier um
kochen und da finde das kind dazu
schreibt was willst du von der raten
muss der erfolge und vor der kamera
ja das steht dann musste jemand aufpasst
und oft ist es so dass andere vorher
bedacht werden
sie können auch nicht einfach sagt anja
b pause das geht ja gar nicht dann
wieder unser social media sehr undankbar
wenn man dann wirklich ein jahr weg ist
du kannst nicht wie im normalen beruf
nach daher nach dem mutterschutz wieder
zurückkommen dann glaubt man immer ein
zwei wochen soll mit solchen bösen
abschließen können wir sagen seit auch
zu anderen ein bisschen sensibler mit
dem thema und wir sind immer sehr
transparent ich glaube in diesem video
warm ist auch wieder sehr ja ansonsten
november war insofern auch super
interessant weil wir auch danach einen
japaner und das auch das was ihr nicht
so mitbekommen
unsere fahnen und trifft für
rausgebracht haben und da kann ich hab
auch wieder ganz viel darüber erzählen
wahlkommission aber dann machen wir ein
extra video zu ja dann bin ich auch
nicht ich sehr sehr happy dass wir das
realisieren konnten ja und im november
und dann richtung dezember habe ich
angefangen mit livestreams auf install
kamen dabei zusammen mit euch gekocht
und gebacken und ich bin am überlegen ob
wir in richtung zu gehen sollen und da
mal öfter mal leitet tritt auch tue ich
vielleicht mal seid ihr schreibt mir
doch mal bitte jetzt rein ist irgend
jemand von euch bei twitter angemeldet
ist der regelmäßig unterwegs und kann
sich vorstellen dass ich lieber dort
live aussagen als die qualität auftritts
ist ja viel geiler als auch instagram
ist ja das hatte aber youtube ist aber
ein bisschen schwieriger von von läuft
gehen her ja also youtube gefällt mir
insofern nicht das sonst immer so
richtig so nachher an sowieso ein rezept
wie so ein rezept toten und dann ist er
mittendrin so eine live stream und das
ist so weiß ich nichts und bringt eine
ordnung durcheinander irgendwie ja und
jetzt sind wir im dezember an gelangen
so den dezember ich bin jetzt ehrlich
der dezember den fand ich ein altes
höheren stellen mit dem mann zusammen
der anstrengendste modell zu erstellen
ja das ist nicht anstrengend ja auch
keine lösung in petto gehabt muss nimmer
quasi von drei tagen zwei tagen drehen
ja wir haben halt immer vorher richtig
viel vor gedreht haben dann drei will
dass die woche für euch raus gar nicht
auch mega gefreut
tja und jetzt das war dein aufholen
diese videos auch jetzt diese krimis
folgen quasi ja es kommt nichts zurück
ja sehr anstrengt zu schneiden
du sagt ich soll drei tage der tage der
wein sein arbeitszimmer und schauen aber
was ist noch passiert im dezember auch
hamza
ach so
oh mein gott ist schon vergessen
das wünschen wir haben einen durchbruch
in der grund sie haben von wurzel wir
haben einfach also das jetzt seit
februar frei und lege ich endlich ein
paar tagen ist der durchbruch komplett
erledigt haben ein riesiges wohnzimmer
und ein abgetrenntes arbeit hier kann
das gegenüber nicht sitzen müsste zu
besitzen gegenüber dir also wenn wir
werden gegenüber sitzen wir müssen nicht
mehr
du bist nicht nur auf dem kleinen sofa
arbeiten und essen falls wir uns nicht
auf ennstal am 4
also man hat schon extrem bitter so man
hat über installation extrem viel 4 1
system also wenn ihr uns da und ich
wollte müsste er sich spätestens jetzt
nachholen
doch dort auch keine gute küche euro ja
genau vergessen und allgemeine ganze
also das essen sei ungefähr 20 nun
fertig sagt dass solche vor hunger ich
hätte wissen also ich bin nicht in
ordnung oder so ähnlich könnte es in
ordnung ja locker locker noch paprika
und so rein tun können aber ich jetzt
einfach kommen spinat hierhin also ja
ich mache nicht nur zwei törchen fertig
so kirche als intellektueller dumme und
deine schöne anrichten eine 31
das trans das ist zuviel nicht ja ich
mache dir gleich fürs foto mit der
kamera machen
du kannst du dabei wenn's nicht so
richtig naja eigentlich müsste ich ja zu
einem salat macht nicht nur schnell
sondern dazu so ein bisschen mehr
vertrauen welches mir freut sich aus
habe bist du schwanger
was also wir wollen uns nicht wir wollen
uns natürlich auch bei euch wie treue
bedanken
warum ist es so dass ich denke ich nicht
gucken sie sich schämt sich willkommen
sagt uns bei euch bedanken die 50 leute
wir möchten uns bei euch bedanken von
ganzem herzen für 400.000 abonnenten
genau für die ganze treuer für dafür
dass er hinter uns steht und dafür sind
wir wirklich sehr dankbar sein kann
daher gesprochen das ist tatsächlich so
du bist du einen kegel nicht die
kopfhörer herunter gefallen egal
bedanken konnten weil sie so aktiv sein
da und support sind auf jeden fall davon
wir uns überlegt wie wir starten jetzt
eine verlosung und zu gewinnen gibt es
also eigentlich gibt's einen besonderen
wird sage ich mal
und die anderen reisen auch besonders
hart actori ja wir haben doch irgendwie
diese komische aber sobald sie ein
bisschen ruhiger geworden ist und wir
uns dann selber dort vorbei ich gerne
hier mit einer von euch wieder
mitgefiebert
genau das heißt ihm kein mensch zuerst
einen zuschuss hatte rolf genau und
natürlich unter und da streng
ich sag mal ich würde auch dafür sorgen
dass wir spätestes machen ich bin auch
dafür sorgen dass wir das auch sehen vor
der kamera genau das sind natürlich
alles seine ordnung brachte aber das ist
aber erst ist wahrscheinlich schon los
erst genau essen soll sich so ein
bisschen beruhigt aber ich wollte das
schon schon länger
machen und ihr wollt das ja auch ihr
habt ja auch immer wenn die chemie des
folge herz gerissen dann kann man fragen
kann man auch mal anfragen von euch auch
kann es nicht mit mir auch das backen
oder was kochen und deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht wir machen sieht so dass ihr
einfach nur so ein kleines 10 20
sekunden video mir schickt genau an die
hier eingeblendete e mail adresse
dass ihr einfach sagt warum ihr gerne
mit mir was banken möchte und damit kurz
vorstellen die genau ihren vorstellungen
genau und dann können wir das sehr gerne
mache mich liebt und dann wollten wir
natürlich auch einen anderen noch was
schenken dass der erste platz ist genau
und dann gibt's noch durch ich finds
gesagt ruhig dann haben wir uns überlegt
jetzt noch 33 100 euro gutscheine von
unserem shop das wäre dann quasi platz
2000 und danach für alle die den 100
euro gutschein nicht gewonnen haben gibt
es dann nochmal drei gewinner die drei
haselnuss krems von uns gewinnen konnten
fünf gewinner für drei jahre los werde
also insgesamt sind das dann zogen die
bürgerkinder insgesamt sitzen neun
gewinner und ihr könnt ihr daran
teilnehmen seite natürlich abonnent das
seid ihr wahrscheinlich sowieso leicht
und ich bin so kommentiert und runter
was sie kommentieren am liebsten würde
ich sagen schreibt doch wie das jahr
2020 für euch gewesen ist und so landen
august noch instagram dahinter falls ihr
es nicht habe dann ist auch nicht
schlimm aber schreibe ist und aufgrund
der leichteren kontaktierung sich mal
genauer nachmittags wechseltrick bands
und kontaktiert und das ist nervig wenn
die kann inter macht es auch keine
schieben wir finden auch wege euch hier
über youtube zu kontaktieren aber du
willst dann doch ein bisschen einfacher
für uns deswegen sage ich das ist wie
gesagt schreiben wir das jahr für euch
war dann quasi im endeffekt runter ins
andere
welche heute nur einen guten rutsch in
ein hoffentlich gesundes neues jahr und
hoffen dass wir auch in 2021 genau so
wachsen wie im letzten jahr genau so
viele schöne projekte realisieren können
klusmann gast war der bereich tätig
kostete gewalt muss ich sagen ich würde
gerne nochmal kommen wird es gehen gerne
gerne ein zweites mal 'nen ich auch
nicht genau was packen aber bitte was
ist möglich auf jeden fall ein paar
tipps
auch bock drauf habt ihr interessante
lassen es sich schmecken
jetzt auf jeden fall wir lassen es sich
schmecken jetzt